so time then for the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
and tonight we'll check out those
headlines with journalist and author
christina patterson and columnist at the
article ali mirage evening to both of
you we'll chat in a second first of all
let's check out those front pages for
you starting with the sunday express the
energy secretary promises that we won't
run out of gas this winter and that
prices will remain capped
the observer leads with news of a
shortage of nurses hitting the nhs a
crisis it says is being made worse by a
drop in recruits from the rest of europe
the mirror says the prime minister has
gone on holiday to marbella while the
country faces a cost of living crisis
on the front of the telegraph boris
johnson faces fresh brexit clash with
parliament and the courts as he calls
for a new deal with the eu over northern
ireland
here's your mail reporting that a work
from home culture in whitehall meant
that documents about uk citizens trying
to escape from the taliban in
afghanistan were missed
the sunday times says scotland yard has
spoken to the american woman who alleges
she was sexually assaulted by prince
andrew the prince has always strongly
denied her claims
and the people has a story about
wildlife campaigner chris packham who
says his car was satellites
and you saw them a moment ago christina
patterson and ali mirage are both with
us this evening uh good to see you
thanks for joining us and let's uh let's
crack on shall we uh christina why don't
you kick things off the sunday express
taking quite a positive stance we will
keep you warm
during winter according to the energy
secretary i'm not sure everyone is quite
as as confident as the express seems to
be
well i think we can generally bank on
the express to be pretty confident and
uh upbeat when it comes to supporting
the government and prime minister on
every single issue
um i'm sure if it could it would say
there is no pandemic everything's
absolutely fine there is no shortage of
petrol but uh all of these things are
not true there is still a pandemic even
though the government barely mentioned
it during their conference this week um
there are still shortages of petrol
and
more related more importantly to
shortages of workers of holiers of staff
in all kinds of areas including sadly
people to work in slaughterhouses so
that 150 000 pigs are going to be
slaughtered and
incinerated because we don't have the
staff and apparently boris johnson
doesn't care about that and nor perhaps
more surprisingly his his wife carrie
who is normally very keen on animal
rights doesn't seem to have made any
comment on this but the the huge issue
facing us
is on energy prices and martin lewis has
been saying this week
along with others that prices are likely
to go up to
000 pounds next year that is a massive
massive rise it's not it may be fine if
you are on a government minister's
salary and if you can go off on luxury
mini breaks to marbella but for most
people in this country a two thousand
pound energy bill is going to be make a
really significant difference to you
know disposable income so it's pretty
scary stuff yeah uh martin is the the
money-saving expert of course some ali
um a lot of accusations thrown at the
government there i mean is there a case
that the government's been caught out
here it was obvious wasn't it that
there'd be a surge in demand for energy
after the peak of the pandemic and yet
there doesn't seem to have been a great
deal of planning for one
well jonathan i think the whole world's
been caught up to a certain degree uh
because we have been a pandemic for the
last 18 months and the world economy is
re-awakening and there's a huge uh
amount of demand globally so you're
seeing when it comes to energy prices uh
gas being brought up quite uh
aggressively by uh chinese state-owned
energy firms you also see the russians
uh using leverage to restrict the gas
supply to get its nordstrom 2 pipeline
which is coming in
from the baltic landing in germany and
wants to get it signed off by german
regulators in short order so it is
restricting gas supplies
and then you have other supplies from
qatar and other places uh being diverted
to uh to to asia so so that's basically
the problem i mean look you can argue
that
structurally the uk should have been
better prepared uh going back many years
for this our gas storage facilities are
some of the lowest in europe we didn't
really uh focus on nuclear being part of
the energy mix to the extent that we
should have now there's talks about a
new nuclear um
plant being built i think edf's being
being lined up for that one and various
other smaller reactors as well uh but
you know we're in this situation right
now it is it is a very difficult one 12
energy companies have already gone to
the wall it looks like uh the business
actually party courting the moment
saying everything will be all right on
the night but i don't think that's
really going to wash and i think the
biggest issue right now is whether this
uh the regulator of gem is going to
review the energy price cap more than
twice a year because energy companies
feel that they need to write raise
prices i mean
this whole issue about the energy price
cap was to protect consumers but we are
in an extraordinary situation here at
the moment and unfortunately uh energy
uh suppliers need to feel that they can
earn a decent uh buck otherwise they're
gonna go bust uh yeah well let's um
let's talk about that next then with
christina front of the sunday times
factories days from closure i mean there
are two issues here aren't there really
small businesses don't have a cap like
households do
but also suppliers are saying that the
price cap in its current form is too
damaging for them i mean it is a real
issue
well when boris johnson famously said
that he wanted to f a word i won't use
business he clearly absolutely meant it
because this government is doing
absolutely everything it can to ensure
that business is having a very very
difficult time it it cuts off its supply
of
uh workers without bothering to do
anything to set any alternative in place
um
as ali says the uh ryzen energy price is
not just limited to this country and uh
good old vladimir putin is playing a
role in this as well as is president
xi jinping i mean you know it's a kind
of perfect opportunity for some of the
world's bad guys to really do their
stuff and squeeze the world and it's
working very effectively but as ali also
said we don't have you know we have a
really we only have i can't remember the
figure but a really really small amount
i mean something like a week's i mean
it's probably not as little as a week
supply uh
um
saved up but in other countries of in
europe they will have months and months
of spare supply so
i think this is putting making life
really difficult farmers are having an
absolute nightmare and
energy companies the government seems to
be perfectly happy for companies to go
fast for
workers to lose their jobs
and even the prospect of factories
having to close down because they
literally will they that i mean i don't
think they're happy about it and to be
fair quasi-cuatang has been uh has been
speaking to business leaders uh um in
the last in the last couple of days and
we'll be putting a lot of this to him
tomorrow when he's interviewed uh by
trevor phillips
well
well
i mean every all business people have
been coming out of those meetings in
despair saying that government is doing
nothing but sorry over to you ellie on
this
well look i mean look just to pick up
some of christina's points even some of
the tories biggest backers and brexit
backers including uh lord wilson the ceo
of next have been coming out and saying
that the government's essentially being
quite tin aired on
on these matters uh particularly staff
shortages as well and the fact that we
have this sort of new economic model
rolled out the conservative party
conference um this week with boris
johnson now sprawling across the center
ground of british politics like a blonde
head sumo wrestler but the issue here is
that
uh businesses are facing uh serious
problems not only with staff shortages
but also energy costs are going up there
are shortages that is a problem we also
don't have enough electricity
interconnectors with other parts of
europe uh to actually sort of deal with
our supply chains i mean i know that
there's a new one that's been looked at
with uh between the uk and ireland
greenlink another one with um germany
called noi connect but they're years
away from completion and this is a real
structural issue that should have been
looked at years ago and we're in a
problem now where there is a peaky
demand we're also looking at
inflationary pressures in the economy
with the bank of england saying that
inflation could got to four percent and
the spectra of all of this jonathan is
interest rates i mean rishi sunak is
very very attuned to this he knows that
he's got 2 trillion of public debt 400
billion of borrowing on the coronavirus
pandemic you know a one percent increase
in interest rates could be leading to
billions in debt servicing for the
government so it's a serious issue even
for the government and for all of us
okay and just finally uh literally a
sentence from each of you on the front
of the sunday mirror uh what costa
living crisis uh the prime minister
apparently has gone to marbella for a
break ali uh is that fair enough can you
have a holiday after the tory party
conference
well look i mean he's master of all he
surveys uh and yes the prime minister is
entitled to a break however as dominic
robb can tell him there's a time and a
place and as dominic rod was on holiday
as the dominoes fell uh in in uh with
the taliban taking town off the town and
he effectively lost his job the prime
minister should be mindful of that
christina very quickly
they've been drinking champagne all week
they've been singing karaoke songs as
they cut the
20-pound uplift universal credit they've
been having a lovely lovely time as
people watch their incomes being shrunk
so i'm sure that looming inflation and a
cost of living crisis and the problems
that this country will face over the
next few months clearly don't bother any
of them but i i it would be nice if they
showed a tiny tiny bit of empathy for
the so-called ordinary people of this
country but they're clearly not going to
want to squeeze a couple of stories in
christina let's start with the sunday
telegraph uh and another brexit story um
it's been a bit quiet recently but it's
uh it's back on the front pages tell us
about this
well um because we haven't entirely yet
shredded our international reputation
they were doing a very good job of it by
breaking pretty much every agreement we
make with uh we've managed to um really
uh irritate france recently germany have
said we're no longer trustworthy the
orchest deal has done a huge amount of
damage and now good old lord frost good
old belligerent
uh pompous lord frost is now doing his
kind of brexit is marvellous and we had
nothing to do with this deal we signed
and it's absolutely crazy deal and
ridiculous and whoever thought it might
work so now we're going to break it
and boris johnson who loves this kind of
um
aggressive testosterone well there is a
technical term which is not really
polite enough for me to use on
television so i won't but let's just say
it involves waving a part of the male
anatomy in a rather aggressive way and
he loves it and he is very happy to see
this go to courts because he so enjoyed
pro-roguing parliament and all that
stuff that he wants to do it all over
again because he clearly thinks he is
king of all he surveyed and he just
wants to you know show yet again that
he's king of the law he's king of europe
he's king of everything
yeah let me get ali's thoughts on this
christina um yeah another clash in the
courts and the house of lords on the
cards
yeah i mean look this is all to do with
the the northern ireland protocol with a
hard border in the irish sea
and the fact that northern ireland is in
the single market the eu single market
for goods and the point is that this is
not really working for um gb and and
northern ireland because there are
checks going in this is causing problems
it's causing problems in terms of the
dup uh jeffrey johnson the head of the
gop is threatening to walk out of
stormont uh and lord frost this week at
the tory party conference on the fringe
was very very direct and very
belligerent uh saying that yes article
16 could be invoked which means that
unilateral action will be taken and and
the and the uk will basically pull out
of the protocol and you also got jake
sullivan the national security adviser
from the u.s
saying that uh this is going to cause
serious problems for stability uh
between northern ireland and the rest of
ireland so and we know that biden is
this is very close to biden's hearts so
yeah a real issue the the positive thing
is marissa rich the vice president of
the eu commission is going to come out
with new proposals this week which are
apparently meant to be meaningful so
let's see all right and uh just finally
um i i guess not unrelated actually in
the sense that that brexit forms part of
this front of the observer christina a
nursing crisis we just simply can't get
enough nurses
no and this is a really really serious
issue actually i 10 years ago i i did a
big campaign in the independent about
nursing because i had had
unfortunately very bad experience is on
nursing even when there were plenty of
nurses around that is not the situation
now i mean you know most nurses are
wonderful at their jobs that they've had
18 months of working in absolutely
impossible conditions and they've had
the workforce decimated by uh by brexit
and we we read that many nurses from the
eu actually received abuse after the
brexit vote and not surprisingly very
few have now applied to work here so now
we're trying to poach nurses from places
in the world where they are very much
needed like india and the philippines
and as always we create this huge
problem blame everyone else when it
happens and the net result is an
absolutely exhausted workforce and less
safe care for people in hospital yeah
we've got 40
sorry christine i'm going to i'm going
to go to ali because we've got 30
seconds left uh very briefly ali 40 000
vacancies
40 000 vacancies and uh 5 million people
on the waiting list and uh christina
mentions some of the numbers back in
2016 we had over 9 000
nurses from the european economic area
we now have under 1 000 left
so not a good position again a
structural problem that needs to be
solved and quickly